you have uh worked on many uh companies
that people who
pay attention to technology especially
over the last 20 years or so we'll know
a number of those companies a number of
those players uh that ran companies
founded companies
what's your biggest lesson learned
through all of that
right whether it comes from the people
the companies like what would you say is
the biggest lesson you learned
through that whole timeline uh yeah
there actually is a biggest lesson oddly
um
and i learned it when i was at mahalo
and mike moritz
uh who is you know fabled sequoia
partner founder um came to visit us one
day
and he had like a q a ask me anything
session
and i asked him the question i said look
you you've you have like 30 years
it was either 30 or 40 years of venture
capital experience at the time
you've seen a lot of stuff what what's
the difference
between the companies that make it and
become big things like apple and google
uh and the companies that just die uh
and i
i really thought the answer was going to
be something like ah well it depends
there's a lot of things a lot of factors
and and he said oh that's easy the the
companies that focus on one thing and
one thing only
and are the best in the world at one
thing have a shot at being the apple or
the google i can't
i can't tell you that for sure they will
but they are at least they at least not
have a lottery ticket and a lot of times
they do win
the companies that definitely fail every
time are the ones that can't make a
direction right they're like
like oh we should oh there's money over
an enterprise so let's let's forget our
consumer thing go over here
right they sort of get distracted by all
these siren songs around them
and those are the companies that die and
and if you're
you know pivoting like you know so so
much you're doing pirouettes
like you're definitely gonna die and
that's the pattern that he's seen
so that's that's sort of a b i would
this is not a direct lesson of mine but
when i heard this it rang very true
there's a guy named bill bill gross
who founded idea lab and he has 30 years
worth of data from that
where he analyzed so they did a study
where they analyzed
what is the difference between the
companies that make it into the
companies that don't he did his own sort
of
you know qualitative quantitative study
is it the team
is it the amount of money is it the
quality of the idea
you know what's what where's the magic
and he's and the answer was very
surprising and very
clear the answer was timing
almost nothing else mattered the biggest
coefficient
of a company's success is timing and
there was absolutely no question about
this so
um so that was a pretty surprising but
very clear finding